mon père a créé cette entreprise une
trentaine d'années ça fait une dizaine
d'années que je dirige excusez mon bac
comme un forcené pour la maintenir à
flot pour moi quelqu'un qui supportera t
personne ne te prêter natta situation je
suis désolé tu dépose le bilan
mon mari est incapable de là et il s'est
arrêté d'insulter drôme affamés office
ta femme est avant tout ma fille c'est
lui qui a raison
tu es vraiment qu'un minable vous prenez
pour qui
pour celui qui a l'argent tu pourrais me
trouver une société bidon et ouvrir un
compte bancaire à l'e3 et genou parle de
pitié de la tva sur du gaz carbonique
tu peux rembourser des dettes et même
garder ton entreprise pourquoi tu
voudrais partager avec nous on est de
fous plus on mise plus offrant antoine c
est internet quand tu fais ça tu as eu
minute maid cheveux pour commencer la
vidéo où est ce qu'on va trouver tout
cet ozenne une voix qui amène un peu de
la boxe peut nous aider non enfin mon
pouce pour nous le plus sûr ce serait
d'ouvrir les comptes offshore
alors on créé notre propre moi de
trouver ça veut dire que si je t'emmène
5 aujourd'hui tu m'as en disant trop
c'est trop grosse à la tour de big c va
leur tomber dessus
[Musique]
la dernière fois que je t'ai vu c'était
pour me dire que tu était criblé de
dettes pro mois après tu reviens avec
les poches pleines d'argent
une voiture qui vaut plus cher que ma
maison tu es un mec qui en toi tu es le
premier mec bien je rencontre dans ma
vie des erreurs de ma vie aurait été
d'avoir totalement sous-estimé ce petit
caux
répondez pris plus de 5 100 briques tout
une pointe avec 10 plaqués tu crois qu
on est quittes
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce que vous avez dans la
tronche bordel on vous n'êtes pas assez
dans la merde comme ça on rigole plus
général d'empiré ne doit jamais et
l'ogbl avait qu'un seul plan le grand
art ce savoir changer pendant la trêve
[Musique]